any vote that I get in Iowa or New
Hampshire uh will count for Biden so the
other guy running for president as a
Democrat as you know is RFK Jr and every
time he says something that makes sense
or he gets some traction or his numbers
go up in the polls the Democrats are
doing everything they can to take this
guy out including changing the rules in
real time about how their primary
process works uh this is RFK Jr on the
Tim Dylan podcast explaining how the
Democrats right now are going out of
their way to rig their own primary one
of the things they've done is they've
made it so that um any vote that I get
in Iowa or New
Hampshire uh will count for
Biden and that and they're trying to do
the same thing now in Georgia they're
trying they how are they doing that well
they're passing a rule that if you any
candidate who who steps into the state
of New Hampshire Iowa to
campaign um will lose all their
delegates and um and so I've campaigned
in both States so I lose their delegates
but now what they're trying to do is is
and they were going to know on September
14th whe they actually do it is they're
trying to pass another rule that if you
step foot in New Hampshire
Iowa that any vote you get in New in
Georgia which a big big delegate State
um will
also uh account for the president and
not for um you know so they're basically
disenfranchising everybody in those
States so there's no campaign and
they're talking
about this idea of making myself and
MaryAnn Williamson as the other
Democratic candidate to pay for all the
primary ourselves you really need to
understand how corrupt the Democrats are
just ask Bernie Sanders about it one day
um the idea that if you step foot in one
of these places Iowa or New Hampshire
your your candidacy is basically a race
now you go well how does that make sense
why would they do that well they're
doing it because they know that Joe
Biden because of name recognition and
being the incumbent he doesn't have to
run last time he ran a basement campaign
we all know that he barely went anywhere
so RFK he wants to be out there Maryann
Williams and no one's going to vote for
her but she wants to be out there they
want to be on the ground meeting people
drumming up Grassroots support that's
what you're supposed to do as a
candidate and the DNC the the party
itself is saying if you show up in this
state if you share your ideas with our
voters we will disqualify you and the
crazy part was the Georgia thing so it's
one thing they're saying if you show up
in Iowa your Iowa votes aren't going to
count and if you show up in New
Hampshire your New Hampshire votes
aren't count now they're trying to pass
this thing if you show up in either one
of those places your Georgia votes
aren't going to count these people are
so
freaking corrupt and you will not hear
about this on MSNBC and you will not
hear about it on CNN or in Washington
Post to the New York Times or anywhere
else RFK explained it uh just a bit more
and I thought he unpacks it in a nice
way it's worth reiterating TNC does not
want a
primary they're effectively
disenfranchising the Democratic voters
from having any choice and who becomes
the Democratic nominee so two of the
things they've done today they made
rules that if any candidate sits foot in
the state of Iowa or sits foot in the
state of New Hampshire that none of the
votes that our cast for that candidate
will be tallied in other words any
delegate that I win in New Hampshire
Iowa would go instead to the president
and now they're trying to change it so
that if I campaign in New Hampshire that
none of the votes cast for me in Georgia
will count and that's significant
because it's hard to win the nomination
with without Georgia if you add up all
the superdelegates that they control and
all of the automatic delegates that just
go to the party and go to the president
I would have to win almost 80% of all of
the states in order to be President
Biden even if he only wins 20% you know
we live at a time in American history
when a lot of Americans think that
democracy is broken that the political
system is rigged and that there's not
really any democracy and unfortunately
the DNC is taking a lot of steps that
that
confirm that Outlook you know you guys
know I often say you don't have to be a
republican but you cannot be a Democrat
you can say what you want about the
Republicans but when the Republicans had
their Insurgent candidate in 2016 2015
actually running Donald Trump they the
RNC itself did not do any tricks to stop
him they had candidates that went up
there and tried to beat him and he took
out Marco Rubio and he took out Chris
Christie and Jeb and everybody else but
the the Machinery of the party they went
along with what the Republican base
wanted the DNC whether you think RFK
could actually beat Joe Biden or not
like he probably can't just because of
name recognition alone and the power of
the presidency and incumbency and all
that but the machine itself is going out
of its way to say screw you Democrats
the DNC d stands for Democrat they don't
like their own voters and they don't
respect their own
voters